EVERYTHING ABOUT IT IS AWFUL.
YOU'VE GOTTA ASK YOURSELF, AS
YOU WATCH THE HISTORIC TRAGEDY
THAT IS JOE BIDEN'S IMMIGRATION
POLICY, WHAT'S THE POINT OF
THIS?
NOTHING ABOUT IT IS AN ACCIDENT,
OBVIOUSLY.
IT'S INTENTIONAL.
JOE BIDEN DID IT ON PERCHES.
BUT WHY?
WHY WOULD A PRESIDENT DO THIS TO
HIS OWN COUNTRY?
NO SANE FIRST WORLD NATION OPENS
ITS BORDERS TO THE WORLD.
PROMISING THE POOREST PEOPLE ON
THE PLANET THAT THEY CAN HAVE
ENDLESS FREE TAXPAYER FUNDED
SERVICES IF THEY SHOW UP AND
BREAK YOUR LAWS?
THAT'S NOT JUST STUPID, IT'S
SUICIDAL.
FOR GENERATIONS MIDDLE CLASS
AMERICANS HAVE HAD ACCESS TO THE
BEST AHEALTHCARE IN THE WORLD,
BUT NOT ANYMORE.
THAT'S OVER FOR GOOD.
OUR SYSTEM CANNOT HANDLE THIS
MANY NEWCOMERS, PERIOD.
IMAGINE WHAT HOSPITALS ARE GOING
TO LOOK LIKE A YEAR FROM NOW.
HOW ABOUT SCHOOLS?
WHAT JOE BIDEN IS DOING NOW WILL
CHANGE THIS COUNTRY FOREVER.
SO AGAIN, WHY IS HE DOING IT?
THERE'S ONLY ONE PLAUSIBLE
ANSWER.
THE SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANIES WILL
SHUT YOU DOWN, SOUTHERN PAWIVETY
LAW CENTER WILL CALL YOU
DANGEROUS, YOU COULD LOSE YOUR
BANK ACCOUNT.
THE LEFT HAS BECOME COMPLETELY
ALL UNHINGED AND HYSTERICAL AND
THAT'S HOW YOU KNOW IT'S TRUE.
THEY ONLY SENSOR THE TRUE
THINGS.
NOBODY GETS IN TROUBLE FOR
CLAIMING THE EARTH IS FLAT.
IT COULD BE FOR US TO EXPLAIN
WHAT'S ACTUALLY HAPPENING HERE,
BUT FOR ONCE WE DON'T NEED TO DO
THAT.
JOE BIDEN HIMSELF HAS ALREADY
DONE IT FOR US.
HERE'S BIDEN EXPLAINING THE
ENTIRE POINT OF MASS IMMIGRATION
BACK IN 2015 WHEN HE WAS VICE
PRESIDENT.
>> AN UNRELENTING STREAM OF
IMMIGRATION, NON-STOP, NON-STOP.
FOLKS LIKE ME WHO ARE CAUCASIAN
OF EUROPEAN DESCENT FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN 2017 WILL BE AN
ABSOLUTE MINORITY IN THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA.
ABSOLUTE MINORITY.
FEWER THAN 50 PERCENT OF THE
PEOPLE IN AMERICA FROM THEN ON
WILL BE WHITE EUROPEAN STOCK.
THAT'S NOT A BAD THING.
THAT'S A SOURCE OF OUR STRENGTH.
>> TUCKER: AN UNRELENTING
STREAM OF IMMIGRATION.
BUT WHY?
JOE BIDEN JUST SAID IT, TO
CHANGE THE RACIAL MIX OF THE
COUNTRY.
THAT'S THE REASON, TO REDUCE THE
POLITICAL POWER OF PEOPLE WHOSE
ANCESTORS LIVED HERE AND
DRAMATICALLY DECREASE INCREASE
THE PORTION -F AMERICANS FROM
THE OLD WORLD.
HE WENT NON WHITE DNA IS THE
QUOTE, SOURCE OF OUR STRENGTH.
IMAGINE SAYING THAT.
THIS IS THE LANGUAGE OF
EUGENICS, IT'S HORRIFYING.
BUT THERE'S A REASON BIDEN SAYS
IT.
IN POLITICAL TERMS THIS POLICY
IS CALL THE GREAT REPLACEMENT OF
LEGACY OF AMERICANS WITH PEOPLE
FROM FAR AWAY COUNTRIES.
THAW WRITE ABOUT IT ALL THE
TIME.  IF YOU DARE TO SAY IT'S
HAPPENING THEY WILL SCREAM AT
YOU WITH MAXIMUM HYSTERIA.
AND HERE YOU HAVE JOE BIDEN
CONFIRMING HIS MOTIVE ON TAPE
WITH A SMILE ON HIS FACE.
NO ONE WHO TALKS LIKE THIS
SHOULD EVER BE THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES.
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES HAS A MORAL OBLIGATION TO
REPRESENT ALL AMERICANS EQUALLY,
NOT JUST THOSE OF A SPECIFIC
COLOR.
FOR FOUR YEARS, REMEMBER, THEY
TOLD YOU DONALD TRUMP WAS A
RACIST, BUT HAS ANYONE EVER
SHOWN THAT TRUMP IN HIS ENTIRE
LIFE SAID ANYTHING HAPPENS AS
WHAT JOE BIDEN SAID ON THAT
TAPE?
NO.
NOEN'S EVER SHOWN THAT.  RETURN
YOU'RE NOT SUPPOSED TO NOTICE
THIS OF COURSE AND TO KEEP YOU
FROM NOTICING WHAT JOE BIDESON
DOING AND WHY THEY ARE AS ALWAYS
ACCUSING YOU OF THEIR SINS.
HERE ARE TWO SITTING MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS TELLING YOU THAT IT'S
RACIST TO ENFORCE IMMIGRATION
LAWS.
WATCH.
>> CONGRESS MUST DO THE WORK OF
INVESTIGATING AND ASSURING
ACCOUNTABILITY OF THE EGREGIOUS
AND WHITE SUPREMACIST BEHAVIOR
OF BORDER PATROL AGENT IN DEL
RIO TEXAS.
>> WHAT WE WITHOUTED TAKES US
BACK HUNDREDS OF YEARS.
WHAT WE WITNESSED WAS WORSE THAN
WHAT WE WITNESSESED IN SLAVERY.
COWBOYS WHIPPING BLACK PEOPLE,
HAITIANS, INTO THE WATER WHERE
THEY'RE SCRAMBLING AND FALLING
DOWN.
AND ALL THEY'RE TRYING TO DO IS
ESCAPE FROM VIOLENCE IN THEIR
COUNTRY.
>> TUCKER: IT'S WORSE THAN
SLAVERY, ENFORCING OUR OWN LAWS
THAT WAS MAXINE WATERS.
EVERYTHING SHE SAID IS A LIE.
THE HAITIANS IN TEXAS ARE NOT
TRYING TO ESCAPE VIOLENCE IN
THEIR OWN COUNTRY, THEY HAVEN'T
BEEN IN HAITI FOR YEARS.
THEY'VE BEEN LIVING IN SOUTH
AMERICA.
MANY EVEN HAD REFUGEE STATUS IN
SOUTH AMERICA, IN COUNTRIES LIKE
CHILE AND BRAZIL.
THAT WASN'T GOOD ENOUGH.
THEY WAITED FOR JOE BIDEN TO
BECOME PRESIDENT AND THEY CAME
HERE FOR THE FREE HEALTH CARE
AND HOUSING THAT JOE BIDEN
PROMISED THEM.
SO NOW THEY HAVE ARRIVED.
WHY WOULDN'T THEY?
YOU WOULD.
WHO WOULDN'T?
SO HERE'S WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE
TONIGHT IN SOUTH TEXAS.
A STUNNING SCENE MORE
REMINISCENT OF A THIRD WORLD
COUNTRY THAN THE UNITED STATES.
OVER 10,000 MIGRANT ARE CRAMMED
UNDERNEATH THE INTERNATIONAL
BRIDGE HERE AFTER CROSSING
ILLEGALLY INTO THE UNITED
STATES.
MANY USING STICKS, PLANTS, AND
WHATEVER THEY CAN FIND TO BUILD
SHELTER AS THEY WAIT TO HAVE
PROCESSED BY BORDER PATROL.
FROM ABOVE A FOX NEWS DRONE
REVEALS THE SIZE AND SCOPE OF
THE CRISIS, SHOWING A CAMP THAT
REACHED A POPULATION OF 15,000
AT ITS CLIMAX BECAUSE OF THIS.
OVER THE WEEKEND WE GAINED
EXCLUSIVE ACCESS TO A BOAT ON
THE RIO GRAND AND WE WATCHED AS
A CONSTANT STREAM OF HUNDREDS OF
MIGRANT CROSSED THE RIVER FROM
MEXICO, ENTERING THE UNITED
STATES ILLEGALLY, HUNDREDS AT A
TIME, GATHERING ON THE SHORELINE
BEFORE WALKING TO THE BRIDGE.
>> TUCKER: SOUND LIKE THE
COUNTRY YOU GREW UP IN?
NO.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO PUT UP WITH
THIS, WE CAN SOLVE IT IN A DAY,
TO SEND THESE PEOPLE BACK
IMMEDIATELY.
HAITIANS ARE NOT BAD PEOPLE, A
LOT OVERTEEM ARE GREAT PEOPLE.
BUT WE HAVE NO OBLIGATION TO LET
THEM INTO OUR COUNTRY.
AMERICAN CITIZENS OAF NO DEBT TO
HAITI.
HATE Y WAS NEVER AN AMERICAN
COLONY, HAITI HAS BEEN AN
IM-INDEPENDENT COUNTRY SINCE
1804.
FOR MOST OF THAT TIME WE HAVE
SENT HAITI A WHOLE LOT OF AID.
HOWEVER SAD AND DYSFUNCTIONAL
HAITI MIGHT BE, IT IS NOT OUR
FAULT, THAT'S FOR SURE.
AND IF JOE BIDEN IS NOW
PUNISHING BORDER PATROL OFFICERS
WHO TRY TO ENFORCE THE LAW, WHO
DARE TO DETER HAITIANS FROM
ENTERING THIS COUNTRY ILLEGALLY,
WITH THEIR RAVENS.  THEY WEREN'T
WHIPS, THEY WERE RAVENS.  IT
DOESN'T MATTER TO THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.  THE OFFICERS'
REAL CRIME WAS TRYING TO DO
THEIR JOBS, TRYING TO STOP
ILLEGAL MIGRATION INTO THIS
COUNTRY.  WILL LIKELY BE
SUSPENDED OR FIRED.
CAN YOU IMAGAGE PUNISHING LAW
ENFORCE.  FOR ENFORCING THE LAW?
THIS IS INSANE.
WHY DO AMERICAN CITIZEN HAVE TO
- - AT THIS POINT.
THAT'S AN HONEST QUESTION.
PEOPLE NEED TO START ASKING THAT
QUESTION.
THE WHITE HOUSE HAS SPENT MOST
OF TODAY CALLING THOSE OFFICERS'
ACTIONS HORRIFIC.
HOW ARE THEY HORRIFIC?
THE WHITE HOUSE NEVER TOLD US.
BECAUSE NO ONE EVER CARED
WHETHER THE WHIP WAS REAL OR
NOT.
JOE BIDEN'S PRESS SECRETARY IS
AN ACCOMPLISHED LIAR SO SHE
UNDERSTANDS THE PRINCIPLE WELL.
HERE SHE IS ONE OF THE GREATEST
CLIPS OF ALL TIME CLAIMING THAT
UNLIKE YOU HAITIANS DO NOT NEED
TO SHOW - -
>> IF SOMEBODY WALKS INTO THE
COUNTRY RIGHT IN FRONT OF THE
RIVER, SOMEBODY NEED A
VACCINATION CARD.
LET ME EXPLAIN TO YOU AGAIN
PETER HOW OUR PROCESS WORKS.  AS
INDIVIDUALS COME ACROSS THE
BOARDER, AND THEY ARE BOTH
ASSESSED FOR WHETHER THEY HAVE
ANY SYMPTOMS, IF THEY HAVE
SYMPTOMS THE DECISION IS FOR
THEM TO BE QUARANTINED THAT IS
OUR PROCESS.
THEY'RE NOT INTENDING TO STAY
HERE FOR A LENGTHY PERIOD OF
TIME.
>> TUCKER: OH.
SO HAITIANS ENTERING OUR COUNTRY
ILLEGALLY FROM GOD KNOWS WHERE
ARE NOT REQUIRED TO SHOW
VACCINATION CARDS BECAUSE,
QUOTE, THEY'RE NOT INTENDING TO
STAY HERE FOR A LENGTHY PERIOD
OF TIME.
REALLY?
SO LET'S SAY YOU GO OUT TO A
RESTAURANT IN MID TOWN MANHATTAN
YOU INTEND TO STAY IN THAT
RESTAURANT FOR A LENGTHY PERIOD
OF TIME, OF YEARS?  NO, YOU JUST
WANT TO HAVE DINNER.
IN ORDER TO GET INSIDE YOU NEED
TO SHOW A VACCINATION CARD.
WHY?
OH, BECAUSE YOU WERE BORN HERE.
YOU'RE NOT HAITIAN.
SO YOU DON'T GET A PASS.
LET'S BE HONEST NONE OF THESE
PEOPLE ARE EVER GOING HOME.
THAT'S JUST TRUE.
ACCORDING TO MEN A HAITIAN
MIGRANTS CAMPED IN THE SMALL
TEXAS BORDER TOWN ARE NOW BEING
RELEASED INTO THE UNITED STATES.
HAITIANS HAVE BEEN FREED ON A
QUOTE, VERY, VERY LARGE SCALE.
FLUNKEN.
WELL, OF COURSE.
IN RECENT DAYS FOX NEWS HAS
CONFIRMED MANY OF THESE HAITIANS
ARE NOT EVEN BEING GIVEN COURT
DATES.
THEY'RE GETTING ADVISORY NOTICES
REQUESTING THAT THEY SHOW UP AT
SOME POINT IN THE FUTURE.
ANY WOMAN CLAIMING TO BE
PREGNANT IS IMMEDIATELY BEING
WAVED INTO THE COUNTRY, NO PROOF
NECESSARY.
HER CHILD WILL BE INSTANTLY AN
AMERICAN CITIZEN.
SO WHO ARE THESE PEOPLE,
EXACTLY?
THESE NEW AMERICANS?
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS NO IDEA.
NONE.  RETURN TO DON'T CARE.
TODAY NOT EVEN SURE HOW MEN A
HAITIANS HAVE BEEN LET INTO THE
U.S. AND HOW MEN A HAVE BEEN
DEPORTED ALL WE KNOW THERE ARE
SEVERAL HAITIANS TRYING TO GAIN
ACCESS TO THIS COUNTRY APPEAR TO
BE VIOLENT.
THIS IS A SCENE AT THE AIRPORT
IN PORT AU PRINCE JUST
YESTERDAY.
[OVERLAPPING VOICES]
>> THE SCENE AT PORT AU PRINCE
AIRPORT IN HAITI IS ANGRY
HAITIANS DROPPED OFF HERE BY THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION THROW ROCKS
AND SHOES AT THE PLANE THAT
CARRIED THEM HOME.
THREE U.S. ICE OFFICERS WERE
REPORTED INJURED DURING
INCIDENTS AT THE TARMAC.
>> THROWING ROCKS AT ICE
OFFICERS.  THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAS MADE IT CLEAR
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO DO ANYTHING
ABOUT THIS OF COURSE.
THE GOVERNOR OF TEXAS ISN'T
DOING MUCH ABOUT IT EITHER, THAT
WOULD BE GREG ABBOTT A RUSKEN.
IN A MATTER OF MOMENTS GREG
ABBOTT COULD DEPLOY THE TEXAS
NATIONAL GUARD TO SHUT OFF THE
SOUTHERN BORDER COMPLETELY AND
REFUSED TO DO THAT.
INSTEAD HE'S DEPLOYED JUST OVER
1,000 OF 19,000 TROOPS HE
CONTROL-S.
WHY IS THAT?
WHY NOT SAVE THE COUNTRY IF YOU
HAVE THE POWER TO DO THAT?
WHY NOT SAVE YOUR OWN STATE?
WE DON'T KNOW.
GREG ABBOTT REFUSED TO COME ON
THE SHOW TO TELL US.
IN A MOMENT WE'LL SPEAK TO O